crushing having fans come back for more
he's a sensation he writes a new minute
every week not easy to do getting
tonight's show started you guys know the
song at
all sing it if you know
[Music]
it some noise
for what's
up Black and Mild more like black and a
child I
uh I think they should introduce a new
submission in the UFC where if you can
hold down your opponent and pretend to
have butt sex with him for 10 seconds
not only do you win the fight but your
opponent now has to
retire cuz if you're in a real fight and
you get butt
[__] but you still win the fight no
one's going to remember that you won the
fight no one's going to remember you got
butt [__] and you're probably going to
have to
move it's been a pretty hot summer as an
Asian I hate it when the temperature
matches my test
scores
I prefer Mexican test
scores 70 to
72 all right thank
you Hans cam ladies and gentlemen with a
brand new minute uh black and child
let's talk about it K on guns a blazing
are you calling cam a child he's very
youthful and
uh
I appreciate that my [__] you know
saying I just want to say [__] Rick Diaz
[__] we GNA kill him yeah it's a little
inside baseball but yes absolutely oh no
I see what you're saying yes Rick Diaz
challenging him uh again and again and
again and he finally uh he finally got
it you are challenging Rick Diaz in the
arena sold out HB Center New Year's Eve
one of you will be doing a new minute
every single week and the other will be
temporarily at least banned from the
show have you been thinking about this
at all yeah I've been uh saving up and
thinking about it and just wondering how
I'm going to crush this European with my
American might hell yeah that's
right hell yeah [__] that [__] Man
David
Jolly Hans Kim I must say that was a
very good minute that you did tday it's
very very
entertaining
thought you were eating
[__] black people get to do the most
racist stuff I wish what I would give
what I would give to just you know what
I'm going to do blackface one day that'd
be a fun episode that's a good idea it's
fun yeah that'd be fun let's switch it
next next week you
host
you host in white face I'll do black
face say you promise what say you
promise no I'll
be I'd be Pinker than a [__] up
here uh Hans Kim I love it the hot
summer the Asian uh scores that all
makes sense that all checks out that's a
real those are good jokes Rock Solid the
UFC but [__] thing I mean I don't
know where does this come from what is
your writing uh routine I guess I
probably never asked you that what's
your like regimen where do you do it are
you at a desk are you at the beach are
you on a toilet in the shower what is it
I'm usually laying down cuz I have a
neck injury uh whoa what's your neck
injury uh herniated disc how did that
happen doing a little
Jiu-Jitsu um I'm a bit of a Jiu-Jitsu
Aro uh I'm up to my third stripe on my
white belt wow it's incredible how often
do you do that I have stopped doing it s
years
ago yeah cam Patterson you w born with a
black belt
[__] you guys usually shoot first
so David Jolly I thought you got that
neck entry off that big ass head
you that big Got the Whole World in His
Head
yeah I actually graduated college
[Applause]
so that is true David Jolly is the size
of the head of a guy that drops out
after a year and a
half you don't have to have a computer
science degree to know that you do have
a pretty big noggin though
Hans it is incredible so you do you do
any uh exercise at all now no Jiu-Jitsu
for 7 years but what's your exercise
routine like these are all questions I
feel like I've never asked you before um
as you can tell I don't exercise too
much um I have a kettle bell 35 lbs that
I do kettle bell Swings with I'm usually
in hotels just doing a foam roller just
to do a little prehab so I don't injure
myself um I have a punching bag I've uh
punched for Tim Welch Sean sugar Shan's
trainer and he said that's pretty good
wow your punching bag what's her name
again
my
girlfriend I know uh Hans another great
minute way to get us started again
anything else I'm missing anything you
want to talk about um you know I made my
career off of a desperate sad comedian
that tried to take other comedians down
and on December uh 31st I'll do the same
at HB Arena wow I love it that's a
[__] promo right there this is what
I'm talking about it's a shame it's
already sold out that the fuing that
would do it that would push us over the
edge um Hans I [__] love you I'm so
proud of you like I said you know jokes
like the hot summer Asian test scores uh
you know things like that the fact that
you just keep writing a new minute at
this pace it's incredible great stuff
Hans Kim everybody go way to get us
started so you see how it goes that's
how it goes when it goes good now this
bucket is filled with people that it
doesn't always go that good